la correspondance dans notre envoyé
spécial emmanuel chaze
gens continuent d'arriver ici à medica à
la frontière directement sur la
frontière entre la pologne qui est
derrière moi et l'ukraine qui se trouve
à une centaine de mètres seulement de
vraiment est bien ici à medica des
centaines de personnes continuent
d'arriver chaque jour ce sont
principalement des femmes ce sont
principalement des enfants et des
personnes âgées également des personnes
en situation de handicap alors elle se
retrouve ici elles sont ensuite évacuées
par le gouvernement polonais via des des
buts qui ont été organisés les bus qui
se trouve juste ici dernièrement ils
sont évacués vers des centres
d'hébergement d'urgence ou alors vers
d'autres d'autres villes polonaises en
tout cas de cette crise humanitaire elle
continue ici à la frontière à la
frontière polonaise ou voyez il ya des
tentes un peu autour de moi des tentes
d'organes de deux ong qui sont présents
pour tenter d'apporter un peu de soutien
que ça soit logistique que ça soit
psychologique que ça soit tout
simplement un peu de nourriture ou des
boissons chaudes aux personnes qui
arrivent et comme vous voyez cette
situation de crise humanitaire qui qui
perdurent près de trois semaines après
l'agression russie